given that you have that sort of
distaste for those activities given that
you equally have a distaste for the
coarsening and cheapening of cultural
life you nevertheless remain firmly
committed to the very economic and
political system which in my view is
largely responsible for that cheapening
and diluting and sensationalizing and
vulgarizing of culture that's what I
really don't understand well that's a
very good
um point to make and I would respond in
the following way that this cheapening
and
commodification of culture that you
rightly criticize is to be observed
everywhere and was to be observed just
as much in the so-called socialist
states that um prevailed in Eastern
Europe in in my youth and in your youth
it doesn't seem to have been resisted in
anywhere anywhere by any political
action partly because I think it isn't
in itself simply the result of of any
political decision it's something that
has come about
entirely because of prosperity because
of uh the ways in which people can make
easily available the cheaper forms of
entertainment without there being any
authority to criticize them and in your
view I mean if if you were in charge I
suspect it would be a bit more uh you'll
be go back a little bit more towards the
Catholic Inquisition about all this uh
actually examining cultural products and
saying you know which should we should
what should we allow everybody would
have to read break three times yes that
sort of thing but um no no I'm not sure
as you know I'm no defender of the
cultural policies of the Soviet Union
I've spent most of my life fighting for
stalinism
okay
well I don't think we agree on the
definition of the problem I spent most
of my life fighting I mean political
terms and also in cultural ones but I
don't agree that the problems of
cultural understandism are anything like
the problems of culture under uh Market
Society they're no better they may well
be worse you know if you have an
authoritarian State telling artists what
to write otherwise they're carted away
to prison sure that's actually worse
than you know the dumbing down of
culture under late capitalism all I'm
saying is one has to diagnose two
different conditions here and the
condition and what I don't understand
about your position is that the specific
forms of vulgarization of culture which
exists under capitalism you rightly
deplore and you support the very
framework which generates them well I'm
not known for for advocating
economic theories I I suspect that I
would uh
I would support
whatever is necessary by way of economic
activity for there to be universities in
the first place but I would agree with
your
position that universities should be
especially in the humanities critical
vis-a-vis the surrounding order that is
that is the function of culture and I
think you said that this has ceased to
be in some way but I think it it ceased
to be largely because people in
universities and in schools have
neglected that that function of of
culture that it in it should inject into
the ordinary way of thinking uh that
those critical ideas which enable people
to distance themselves from the obvious
Temptations of economic life I think I
think the distancing is part of the
problem
um
the way you culture on the humanities
were actually set up historically the
way we if you like the origin the modern
origin of the humanities oral culture
was in that necessary distancing for
themselves from an increasingly
industrial society so that values which
were really dysfunctional in that
Society were increasingly as it were
expelled and had to be preserved
somewhere else you had to have an
enclave
which actually preserve these values you
call it the Arts or the humanities or
University or culture doesn't matter the
problem however and I think this is you
see that side of it Roger and you
applaud it and so do I but I see another
side too that distance is also crippling
that distance which is necessary as it
were to preserve those values in some
utopian or residual way also means it's
impossible to bring them actively to bed
close the distance without the the
apparatus of sensors you and I both were
at the same College in Cambridge and
knew each other a new
um uh Raymond Williams who was my who
was my mentor if you like now when
Williams talks about the culture and
Society tradition he is indeed talking
about figures who want to preserve
certain kinds of value from the
depredations of industrial capitalism
all the way from you know almost Burke
to Lawrence but he's also talking not
least in the in the case of people like
William Morris and to some extent wild
about people the point where that
tradition become as it was is sees that
the only way forward is to try to link
these values to a political movement
that's where of course you will pull
back because a typically conservative
view is that culture is one thing in
politics there's another if that is the
case case I'm afraid there's no way of
bringing these values to bear on
everyday social practices that's my
problem with this position